well so this goes back to the
conversation we were talking about
before
let me pull up this story i find very
very strange and it's about the pods
basically
from from business insider most
millennial homeowners regret
buying their home survey fines that just
reeks of me of propaganda yeah
where you're paying less than you would
for rent and you're keeping all the
equity except for the interest no no you
don't want to do that
it's a terrible thing is it does it say
why does it say like millennials want to
move around more
or is does it even give anything they
say 20
said expensive maintenance costs and 13
said it was because they overpaid and i
look at that and i'm like
this article to me reeks of live in the
pod
we've already got all the eat the bugs
articles the cicadas by the way the
cicadas are getting smaller
so i went outside today and that's
because the big ones are getting eaten
well no no i think it's because the big
ones the strong ones
came out earlier and then died and
what's happening now is the weaker ones
have have been slow to emerge and
they're much smaller so we're close to
the end of the cicada swarm
but the the media has been saying eat
the bugs like crazy even tucker carlson
is like i'm
going to eat a bug live on tv it's
delicious
on tv the illusion you think you
shouldn't eat bugs
of course you can't of course of course
of course you can't
actually of everything yeah actually
the the the best tucker is using
actually at the end of a sentence
yeah that is very and then when when he
has a guest on it that's a voiceover he
just goes
sheamus wants you to think that you're
not supposed to eat bugs actually you
are
actually but actually people around the
world eat bugs
and they enjoy it so what about lobster
people eat that lobster or lobster is a
bug though yeah
lobster crab that's right antifa and
bugs
so okay read about antifa's diet in my
new book at antique
dot com yeah so what did you like to
study them like animals yeah yes yes i
do
this is what they consume these are you
should in chats they
they had a whole like co-op with food
and everything so
yeah i'm eating no bugs so it's true
there are no confirmed there's no bugs
you should you should do a video spoof
you should do it you should you should
do a video spoof with uh shots of antifa
and do like the
earth style documentary right the young
auntie that's exactly right
approaches the female and performs his
dance a mating ritual it doesn't work
anyway anyway we're talking about eating
the bugs and then we'll have the snoop
dogg version on top of that
yeah i got some questions about this
article well so so they're it's it's an
article it's not the only one right
there's also this other story from
reuters that says u.s consumers sour on
housing markets buying conditions i mean
i guess that's true because the ultra
wealthy are buying up these houses
but bro they're saying live in the pod
and eat the bugs the people who don't
buy houses
have you seen apartments in new york
they are pods
dude i remember watching these these
stories on like the news or they're like
this apartment
goes for three thousand dollars it's a
closet yeah it's literally a closet
and they're like it's a bed in it i mean
i mean hong kong is basically like that
you know they've got these really tiny
cramped apartments no there's there's
like a subreddit dedicated for these
really awful tiny apartments where it's
like a bed next to a toilet in a closet
well there's
there's even worse if you look at some
of the illegal housing
structure they have set up in hong kong
and beijing where it'll be these sort of
like large
kind of kind of like room room right now
but inside the room they'll have
essentially what looks like uh steel
rack
bunk beds and then you can rent one of
the bunks
and you might be in a room with like 80
other dudes
and you know here's a family that's got
like two bunks right but it's like
five people and that's it and you go to
work and you come back to your bunk and
it's like the pod would be like a step
up from some of that stuff wow yeah oh
yeah
well that's where we're going um so i i
think it's time and we'll
love it yeah right you will you will own
nothing and you'll be happy
they make that video but you know what
they're not wrong they're not wrong
people can look is what i was saying
earlier today if
you were born in the 1400s are you going
to complain about not having a
smartphone you wouldn't know what
smartphone is
are you guys complaining about not being
able to teleport right now no yes well
all the time sometimes how long it takes
me to drive here yeah
because teleporting just kills you and
recreates you in another place
that's true that's right so is it really
is it really you yeah yeah
yeah well so so look right now there's a
bunch of technology that'll exist a
hundred years we don't know about right
and we don't have access to it
i mean we're we're relatively happy
that's what it is so they so this is
what they're exploiting they're they're
exploiting that if
if the if the serfs have access to
knowledge
then they will become unhappy with their
circumstances so they want us
to be ignorant the people who are
following the mainstream media
not watching shows like this not getting
a critical uh thought process through
they're just gonna brian selter said it
so it must be true i'm happy
they're gonna get their home taken away
from some ridiculous they're gonna say
oh no because of covid we've gotta take
your house now and
they're gonna go well if it saves one
life that'll be it
and then people who aren't in those
states and red states this is this is
what's crazy
the red states are going the direction
desantis abbott no vaccine passports new
york california illinois washington
yes so what happens new york says if you
want to go to these businesses you need
to vaccinate
the excelsior pass they call it so what
happens if you're visiting from texas
just a tourist you want to go visit
sorry can't come in we don't like your
kind around here
yeah so people won't go what will happen
is
people who live in new york who don't
want to live under a vaccine passport in
a pod or eating bugs
will move to texas texas will then
become ideologically homogeneous among
people who
like freedom don't want to live in pods
or eat bugs ooh i don't know about that
man
because i think a lot of people will
leave these blue states for a red state
but still vote for all the horrible
things that destroyed their state in the
first place they'll go like oh i really
don't like all of these things the
government's forcing me to do so i'm
going to move somewhere where i'm more
free but then they're just going to vote
for all the same stupid stuff that
destroyed their places i don't think so
because
the reason i disagree with that is the
the people in uh blue states
who are four vaccine passports are happy
with them and demanding them
there there are these tick tock videos
where the girls like i can't believe
our governor just banned vaccine past
parts like
how dumb they're not they don't want to
live there they want to leave and people
in new york are like
why don't we have more what what
advice.com write they wrote this other
this article the other day
why aren't we mandating vaccine
passports these people are going to jump
and cheer to be in new york getting
locked in under these things
and every and people who don't like that
will leave not wanting to live that way
and then you will have an actual
physical divide between states
and ideology and then it's like the
politicians from washington
and the politicians from you know utah
or whatever or whoever else passed the
ban on vaccine passports they are going
to be like totally different countries
no
shared culture completely at odds and
then what happens
what happens when new york says you get
cuomo being like we have to have vaccine
passports
because of the the potential for a fifth
wave and then he says
we're gonna have to lock down the
borders like we did last time and do
checks for people who are vaccinated
when the pandemic first started they had
cops at the
at the roads into and out of manhattan
that's already started to extend with
this this
and i think they keep changing the name
of the indian variant or the nepalese
variant they keep
but there there's already people saying
that we're not sure
if the current vaccines that have been
rolled out will be effective against the
new variant which is always sort of like
one of the corollaries with the vaccine
right that
hey this may not affect new variants
well it looks like the thing that's
that's actually
spreading across india and is now you
know particularly continuing
may not be affected by the current they
may we don't know effective yet so what
happens then if you live in texas
or florida or north carolina is is an
east coast state it voted for trump and
they have a substantially lower uh ratio
of vaccinations
what happens if you live there and
you're you try to go to new york they're
not gonna let you in
they're literally gonna borrow you and
be like ah if you're not vaccinated you
can't come i don't know
then you'll have but yeah you say oh no
for sure kidding because
yeah no but the seriousness of it is a
hard device it's a very different
issue than just like you know
you see it with gun owners right now so
they have the they have like the
drive-through laws that you
like i if i am a gun owner but i'm
driving through a state
like new jersey or i'm driving through
new york well
as long as i'm not stopping and you know
spending substantial amount of time
in that state then i can still have my
guns in the car i'm just driving through
right this isn't my
my final destination as long as you you
know you're following you know you have
to be broken apart and ammo has to be
separated etcetera etcetera
but you can physically have them this is
different because
it's i will not go to that state number
one
or i do not want people from that state
coming here number two and that's only
going to lead i mean
uh sports teams but you know what
happens with sports teams then do they
still play
right are we going to is that going to
be allowed et cetera what happens when a
texas-based sports team
i'm sure which has many conservatives
playing on the team just don't hear
their politics and they're like you know
i talk to my doctor
vaccines not right for me i don't feel
like doing it then they're like well if
you want to go play at the world series
or whatever
against the yankees in new york you have
to otherwise you can't go in and they'll
become
there this is a hard divide so a lot of
people talked about
it's the olympics right now by the way
is fantastic that's why
you know we were supposed to be like
gearing up for okay we had the 2020
olympics
postponed to 2021 uh summer started
you know where's the olympics like
where's the gear up towards it and in
tokyo they're freaking out the
the i was one ioc guy just committed
suicide just threw himself in front of
the subway it's horrible because the
sheer amount of
pressure that's on them because of all
this and all these athletes
and you know you look at some of these
sports by the way
where you know like a lot of them they
they live
off of the olympics right you can't the
whole sport collapses without that
you know that olympics itself every four
years um and so
you know you realize that all of these
questions are having very
real consequences now right now in real
time
and are we going to get to a situation
where i mean i think i think
you know you think of like like the late
night comedy oh
those people in texas they won't come up
you know imagine how insufferable
jimmy kimmel is going to be right once
that starts but imagine then
how radical so if jimmy kimmel is the
leading edge of it right
then how radical will the even the more
radical people become
towards people from somebody walking
down the street with a you know
cowboy hat on does you do you become a
target now thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast
irl monday through friday at 8 pm where
you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you